Canha NFL player being a kid chef
probably not I'm Donovan and I was on
season five of MasterChef junior you
think what it would take to become
America's next MasterChef junior
I've been talking for six years and I
think I can be whoever I'm against
tonight
someday Marlo I played for the Buffalo
Bills I'm no professional chef I like to
cook at home
I appreciate the culinary art aspect you
ready to cook it yeah I'm a little
nervous I wanna go against you you
should be I think breakfast foods are
easy and it's one of the first foods
I've learned how to make a breakfast
cereal in your dish that's difficult
cereal I don't have a lot of ideas on
how I can use it I don't know what to do
but I'm gonna do something good luck the
first thing I see when I open the doors
is three avocados the first thing that
goes into my mind is avocado toast I
need some cilantro cuz I'm gonna make a
little salad with the tomatoes and onion
and some olive oil the avocado since
it's avocado toast
we're going to beyond the bread they had
to go on top and bread for the toast
so when I looked at the serios I was
trying to find something that didn't
have a lot of flavor I can make it into
the avocado toast more sneakily my
students let's check out what's in this
fridge when I opened up the refrigerator
I seen bread avocado onions eggs spinach
if I can mash up some avocado boil some
eggs mash them together make a avocado
egg toast sprinkle some cereal on the
top some Apple Jacks cuz the color so it
might look nice with this avocado egg
toast and I'm gonna make
I think would be pretty good it would be
a weird concoction that people will try
so we'll see how scone tastes
I saw a Dean basically the same
ingredients as me he's making the same
thing I'm making is just gonna make it
look the key to winning is focusing on
what I'm doing because I don't want to
get pressured if I see him making
something that will go better I heard
his knife and board like sounds of a
chef when I hear that I'm like he's
doing some work over there at one point
I looked over and he was cutting the
onions it was a bit different than mine
Donovan was in his sanctuary he was not
worried about me he was focused on his
prize and I was more worried about him
than I was worried about making my own
dish don't the half of the lemon oh yeah
he seemed like he was struggling a
decent bit I gave him half of my lemon
as much as we were against each other he
was also looking up would you give me
any advice about this certain dish I
don't really want to because it might
when he was serious but who's your
favorite artist I like boogie
a buggy with the hoodie ho go skies low
sky who's that little Scott I mean I'll
I know a lot of lows but I don't I don't
know who little sky
[Music]
what kind of egg you call that a poached
egg
I've heard of poached eggs but I never
actually seen someone cooked up okay hey
I want to see em because my favorite
part about a good avocado toast is the
runny yolk I just think it pulls the
dish together I'm making a boiled and
mashing it's actually a good idea
I think the hard-boiled was since I
mashed it you don't want the runny yolk
and stuff when you're mashing the eggs
and he put it in the avocado which I
thought was unique this is something
easy for you the way you even hold it on
the knife you just got in my head the
guide of my egg I'm starting to plate
now he doesn't seem like he's incredibly
far in his dish he was still mashing his
eggs and avocados I think I'll be done
in 10 minutes I got to step my game up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I looked over at Dean Station and who's
picking the green Apple Jacks
out of the box which was kind of weird I
guess mom looks like a toddler baby his
food
visually doesn't look that appetizing
everything on his plate was green that
kind of looks weird his looked like a 37
year old 15 year pearl chef just made
that so we're gonna ask the judges to
come down and see whose tastes better
that looks better because we know whose
looks better it's really good nice
poached eggs good seasoning I kind of
want like a little more salt just
because it's so fatty with the a genomic
on it but it's really good I like the
layers and flavors and the colors that
they have going on pretty solved this
one looks like st. Patrick's Day
exactly not bad doctor part of
interesting it's kind of like thank be
honest I don't know what I'm eating I'm
confused
cinnamon is a nice sort of touch to put
to something that is normally savory
this is kind of those dishes that got to
do a little bit thinking about I think I
would like Apple Jacks serving normally
as well out of the two this is the first
one was definitely the best it looked
like something I could pay for in a
restaurant and I was pleased to eat it
as much as I loved the first one and it
is something that I would normally go
for the second one I have to give it
points for creativity
so my winner would be the turning circle
with cereal avocado toast after a wild
adventure of avocados bread and
mysterious name objects number one was
just solid all around got color got
taste as texture number one is my
favorite in this position NFL player
versus Keyshia the winner goes to
I want to taste it
[Music]
it's not bad there's always Apple Jacks
oh my god watch menu
[Music]